thank you heat and wind is a dangerous
combination for any day especially for
this Fourth of July Holiday 8 News Now
weather reporter Mary Jane Bailey
sharing safety safety Vice on
so dry that they would go up like a
match Joel Gibson has owned a home in
the West Valley for 10 years and every
year he cleans up firework debris from
his yard he's doing some cleanup work
before the holiday as he knows how
hazardous fireworks can be I have a low
pitch roof and it catches everything
that flies our way and usually my
property is littered with these
incendiary devices that's what I call
them because they're basically matches
they had two large Bristlecone pine
trees in my front yard and uh they were
they weren't very healthy because of the
drought it is recommended to take care
of it right away Mikhail imageanov owns
Vegas best tree service he says his crew
has been busy with service calls if you
feel there's any danger to the dead
trees or plants
call us even tonight
eminyanov knows the danger first hand my
parents have a second apartment that got
on fire because of the fireworks proper
maintenance includes making sure tree
limbs and shrubs aren't touching your
home and routinely remove dead leaves
and sticks from your yard close to 120
out there Boulder City meteorologist
Matt Woods from the National Weather
Service says elevated to critical fire
conditions are possible yeah when you
have kind of a bunch of dry grasses on
the fourth of July a lot of people
shooting off fireworks and then you have
these increased winds where we could see
wind gusts around 30 miles an hour you
know we're kind of setting the stage for
some fire potential woods and Gibson
both agreed to leave the fireworks to
the professionals shoot them off
maybe on like a paved surface a flat
level surface keep them pointed to the
air that way they have time to burn out
before they reach the ground
and remember to only remove dead palm
tree fronds think of your palm tree as a
clock pruning them down to the nine to
three position or ten to two